this former coal mining town used to be
a stronghold of the Socialist Party but
in 2014 after decades of high
unemployment and a corruption scandal
that hit the former mayor the fro
national swept to power in in a Boomer
mcconaughey on a visit as soon as we
took over we lowered local taxes and
improved local services no other
municipality in the region has done that
or the others are just increasing taxes
without doing anything for the citizens
we have a pragmatic way of operating
which is devoid of any ideology we make
it work by saving money and being more
efficient then you added illusion to fix
a function of am your leader nipply
confidantes economy local unemployment
remains high one in five is out of work
but many inhabitants still feel the
front of chanel is taking better care of
them regardless of the parties
anti-immigration stance support the town
is clean they are organizing a lot of
activities and the mayor shakes hands
with us he talks to us that means a lot
Rebecca shall be modern resolve it was
romantic my husband had serious health
problems so we applied for new social
housing because our elevator just
wouldn't work the old mayor just ignored
me but then I met the fro national
leader marine lepen here at the market
and she told me to send her my documents
so I did even though I didn't think she
would help us but two weeks later had
loads of different offers casual data
tool associate mr plea is what your
device was the front of you now wants
our jobs to go to the French it's right
not to want to take in all the
immigrants we have enough financial
problems and need to look after
ourselves but not everybody here feels
supported by the phone arsenal this a
group is being expelled from its
premises without the town providing new
officers
the anti-poverty NGO says it's a way to
get rid of them because some of the
members are left-wing rather not
rational select mature male in a boom or
my last conversation with the mayor he
very clearly said that he thought we had
a political agenda but I told him we
didn't we have nothing to do with our
members political orientation we are
politically neutral since that
conversation they could have easily
found a solution but things are stalling
the city government is dragging its feet
in the hope that we just give up and y
como de Mestral tara the- Oscar more
modern Emma Dallas acute peril these are
world but that Pascal value complete on
Bonjour the opposition also has a tough
time in the City Council they number six
against the front Arsenal's 29 members
the opposition is literally getting
shouted down by the majority the phone
Arsenal is using another showcase and
has brought in its top talents it's very
difficult to stand our ground in such
circumstances and convince anybody to
vote for us this is a real war machine
in Google the front as soon as members
say they are just defending themselves
against a very aggressive opposition but
the party stands on a local level could
be an indication of how they treat their
opponents on a national level should
they get elected in the upcoming
presidential elections